our subject today is simon mcneil he's a
self-professed
medium he's almost here
for those of you that don't know i've
recently lost my son miles
people like simon like to prey on grief
ready whenever you are i need complete
darkness
or rather they do
[Music]
all the dead have stories
there is a place where these horrors are
transcribed
i'm not sure where i'm going i felt like
i was being
followed we're headed to more
is it a nice place no
here the dead there's so much closer
than you realize
[Applause]
i wasn't planning on stopping i just
think i'm really tired
come on you're safe here
i just have a thing with noises it's
neurological
would have probably been better if i
just didn't stop taking the meds
oh i'm so sorry dear i didn't mean to
startle you
and some bad [ __ ] happened to you urban
decay that's what happened
we like to think everyone who stays here
is family
we all die but sometimes the stories of
her passing
must be forever carved into our
collective memory
all stories end here